BLUDGEONED DONALD TRUMP.
HERE WITH REACTION FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR NEW YORK
COLUMNIST MICHAEL GOOD WIN
IS WITH US, FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY ARI
FLEISCHER, ALSO A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
HERE IT IS, DEMS LOVE
REPUBLICANS, WHEN THEY'RE
DEAD.
MICHAEL GOOD WIN, THE FACT
IS IT'S TRUE.
>> YES, IT IS SAD, SEAN, YOU
ARE RIGHT.
AND AS I POINT OUT IN THE
COLUMN THIS ALL SOUNDS
SIMILAR.
THE -- HE IS A HERO.
IS HE A GENTLEMAN.
IS HE A PATRIOT.
IS HE A GREAT AMERICAN.
AND THEY SAID THE SAME THING
ABOUT JOHN HIS COFFIN.
WHEN THEY WERE ALIVE THE
SAME MEDIA ATTACKED THEM
RELENTLESSLY, ACCUSED THEM
OF RACISM.
STIRRING UP FOMENTING
TROUBLE EVERYWHERE.
TAKING THE COUNTRY
BACKWARDS.
THEY ATTACKED THEIR SUPREME
COURT NOMINEES WITH THE SAME
WAY THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS
ATTACKED.
SO THERE IS A PATTERN,
EXCEPT WHEN THEY DIE, THEN
SUDDENLY THEY WERE THE GREAT
AMERICANS.
IN THIS CASE, OF COURSE,
THEY ARE BEING USED, VIRTUES
ARE BEING USED AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S REALLY A DOUBLE WHAMMY
FOR THE DEMOCRATS IN THIS
DAY AND AGE.
>> Sean: THEY DID THE SAME
THING WITH RONALD REAGAN,
JOHN MCCAIN, ARI, WITH 41
AND 43.
YOU'RE VERY CLOSE TO THE
BUSH FAMILY YOU WERE THERE
WHEN THEY WERE BLUDGEONING
43.
THAT WAS A DAILY -- I DIDN'T
THINK IT COULD GET WORSE BUT
IT'S GOTTEN WORSE.
>> YEP E WHEN I DIE ALL YOU
LIBERALS THROUGHOUT THAT
HATE ME DON'T CHANGE WHAT
YOU REALLY THINK OF ME.
JUST SAY IT BE BE HONEST.
IT'S ALL RIGHT.
I WILL GIVE YOU A PASS FROM
HEAVEN IF I'M EVER INVITED.
IN.
>> SEAN, YOU KNOW, HERE'S
THE ONE THAT TO ME SPEAKS
VOLUMES "NEW YORK
VOLUMES GNEW YORK
VOLUMES GEOW YORK
VOLUMES GEORGYORK
VOLUMES GEORGE RK
VOLUMES GEORGE H.W. BUSH
WENT TO VISIT A TRADE SHOW
AND SAW AN ABSOLUTE BRAND
NEW TECHNOLOGY FOR SCANNING
PRODUCTS AT A SUPERMARKET.
NOBODY HAD SEEN IT BEFORE.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" STORY
FRONT PAGE BUSH ENCOUNTERS
THE SUPERMARKET, AMAZED.
HERE IS THE LEAD OF THE
STORY.
THE CAREER POLITICIAN WHO
LIVED A CLOISTERED LIFE OF A
TOP WASHINGTON BUREAUCRAT
FOR DECADES IS HAVING
TROUBLE PRESENTING HIMSELF
TO THE ELECTORATE AS A MAN
IN TOUCH WITH MIDDLE CLASS
LIFE.
THIS NOW IS THE MAN THAT
"NEW YORK TIMES" AND OTHERS
ARE HOLDING UP AS A ROLE
MODEL FOR ALL AMERICANS
BECAUSE OF HIS GOODNESS,
BECAUSE OF HIS PRINCIPLE,
BECAUSE OF HIS CIVILITY.
THEY MOCKED HIM
RELENTLESSLY, THE THING
ABOUT THAT STORY IT WAS
100 PERCENT FABRICATION.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" WASN'T
EVEN AT THE EVENT AND THAT
WAS NOT WHAT BUSH WAS AMAZED
ABOUT.
AND THE "NEW YORK TIMES."
>> Sean: DAN RATHER LIED
ABOUT 43.
>> THEY HAVEN'T CORRECTED IT
YET.
THAT'S RIGHT DAN RATHER LIED
ABOUT 43.
FABRICATED INFORMATION ABOUT
BUSH.
>> Sean: IF YOU ARE
SOFT-SPOKEN LIKE 41 YOU ARE
A WIMP IN THE MEDIA'S EYES.
IF YOU ARE COMBATIVE LIKE
DONALD TRUMP YOU ARE A BRUIT
AND THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE TO
THE OFFICE.
SO, YOU CAN'T WIN, CAN YOU
IS IT AND NOW ALL THE SUDDEN
THEY HATED 43 ARI, NOW THEY
LOVE HIM.
WE WOULD TAKE HIM BACK IN A
MINUTE.
NO, THEY WOULDN'T.
HE THIS WOULD BE ALL OVER
HIM IN FIVE SECONDS.
>> I REMEMBER IN THE 2,000
CAMPAIGN WHEN GEORGE H.W.
BUSH WAS RUNNING AGAINST
JOHN MCCAIN, THE PRESS WAS
ALL FOR JOHN MCCAIN.
I REMEMBER THINKING TO
MYSELF AS SOON AS JOHN
MCCAIN WERE TO BEAT GEORGE
H.W. BUSH THEY WILL GO
AGAINST JOHN MCCAIN.
THAT'S THE WAY THEY ALWAYS
ARE.
>> Sean: MICHAEL.
>> LOOK AT THE WAY JOHN
MCCAIN WAS TREATED WHEN HE
RAN AGAINST BARACK OBAMA.
THEN HE WAS JUST ANOTHER
DIRTY REPUBLICAN.
THEY LOVED HIM IN 2,000 BUT
BY 2008, HE WAS JUST ANOTHER
DIRTY REPUBLICAN.
ENOUGH TO HE IS DEAD SO HE
IS GREAT.
>> Sean: YEAH, AMAZING.